à marioupol en ukraine nouvelle
opération d'évacuation était prévue ce
lundi mais on a très peu d'informations
à ce sujet en revanche un premier
corridor humanitaire a pu avoir lieu
samedi les premiers rescapés sont
attendus à ça pour hijja c'est là que
vous vous trouvez tariq khan bonjour
tarek vous attendez donc l'arrivée des
premiers bus
tout à fait on est toujours aussi en
attente de ces bus qui devrait arriver
aujourd'hui en principe très peu
d'informations circulent justement des
informations précises sur ces bus les
représentants de l'onu qui sont présents
ici avait affirmé à 14h et craignent
haine que ces bus arriverait dans deux
ou trois heures ce n'est toujours pas le
cas ici comme je le disais il est
extrêmement difficile d'avoir des
informations fiables et précises sur
l'heure d'arrivée sur le nombre de
personnes ou s'il s'agit d'enfants et de
femmes ou six lauréats avec des hommes
ce qui se dit aussi ici c'est que ces
personnes dont qu'arriverait il
s'agirait peut-être d'une centaine de
personnes comme on disait il s'agit du
premier convoi en fête humanitaire
évacués de cette usine de d'azov talent
des premières personnes qui arrivaient
disons en terrain ukrainien ou en dehors
des territoires occupés donc pas là
réussi ici comme vous le voyez derrière
moi il ya tout un dispositif pour
accueillir ces personnes un dispositif
je dirais modeste il ya quelques
organisations humanitaires qui sont
prêtes pour les accueillir on a vu
certaines organisations comme médecins
sans frontières il ya également d'autres
organisations
ukrainienne j'ai pu parler par exemple
avec un psychologue ukrainiens qui
s'attendent justement accueillir des
personnes éprouvées par ces semaines
extrêmement difficile il s'agit donc des
convois on attend les convois officiels
et convoi eut le temps mais également
des voitures qui arrivent derrière moi
comme vous le voyez il s'agit de deux
ces voitures là
qui ont pu se débrouiller toutes seules
des personnes qui ont pu profiter de
cette trêve pour quitter l'enfer de
marioupol et venir ici à zaporijia et
oui tard et que ce corridor humanitaire
qui a été ouvert samedi il a été aussi
empruntée par des civils de marioupol
qui n'était pas forcément coincés dans
cette usine
tout à fait il était à marioupol mais
pas asos talent il arrive toujours on a
pu parler avec certains parmi eux j'ai
pu parler par exemple avec vous le voyez
par exemple derrière moi cette voiture
avec des affiches le ruban blanc pour
dire qu'il s'agit de civils mais
également il ya la fiche des ti ce qui
veut dire enfants pour signaler qu'il
s'agit donc de civils avec des enfants
j'ai pu parler donc avec un homme qui
disait qu'il avait vécu pendant un mois
dans saga dans sa cave complètement
coupé du monde puisque le réseau de
téléphonie mobile ne fonctionnait pas il
disait qu'ils eussent des fois il devait
faire fondre la neige pour pouvoir boire
il parlait également de ces corps qui
étaient dans les rues qu'on avait
enterré à la va-vite à 1/2 à m de
profondeur pour pouvoir les enterrer
dignement plus tard j'ai pu parler
également avec une femme qui était qui
parlait de ce bonheur qu'elles avaient
éprouvé en arrivant en territoire
ukrainien elle avait fondu en larmes
quand elle avait vu les soldats
ukrainien il y avait un mot qu'elle
répétait inlassablement par décrire ce
qu'elle a vécu terrible terrible
terrible c'est ce qu'elle a vécu donc
dans cet enfer de mariupol